joining the sunlight and Senator Ted
Cruz senator Cruz of course senator for
the state of Texas and a host of verdict
available anywhere you get podcasts
senator Cruz great to talk to you sir
man great to be with you so what is the
latest in terms of the congressional
negotiations around the next tranche of
funding for the for the Patient
Protection Program well it appears we
finally got a deal and and I'm hopeful
that that by the end of the day the
Senate will have passed out additional
funding for the Paycheck protection
program Republicans tried to do this
over a week ago the program gave
guaranteed low income loans to small
businesses to keep small businesses
alive to keep their employees on salary
to keep them getting paychecks and it
ran out of cash last week and sadly the
Democrats have blocked funding for this
program for for over a week and really
just playing partisan politics with it I
think they get finally given in so
hopefully it will be replenished today
or tomorrow now senator Cruz how long do
you think this can go on in terms of
just Congress continuing to fund
business without people getting back to
work obviously we're seeing across the
country a lot of roiling conversation
about how people should go back to work
what level of necessity in terms of
tests is is is really required in order
for people to get back to work where do
you stand on how fast people should get
back to work and how should we go about
doing that we have got to get back to
work and and and there's a balance here
that there are two national crises going
on simultaneously there's the public
health crisis of the corona virus
pandemic and that is serious and over
170,000 people have died worldwide but
there's also the economic crisis and and
that is devastating and and it has cost
over 22 million people their jobs it is
destroying small businesses it is
destroying people's livelihoods and and
that likewise is going to cost lives if
we continue producing poverty and
destroying everything people have worked
for that's that's going to increase
mental illness and depression it's going
to increase suicide rates and substance
abuse and alcohol abuse that's going to
cost real lives so we got to balance
them both we our objective should be to
save as many lives as possible to
protect people and protect them
lies that means that we should continue
working to slow the spread of the virus
but we need to get people back to work
and that's got a very geography by
geography region by region so for
example that as you know New York City
has been horribly horribly hit by this
it's breathtaking how bad it is nobody
would argue New Yorkers should go back
to work tomorrow but there are a lot of
places in the country that that
thankfully have not endured anywhere
near those levels and we ought to allow
young healthy people to get back to work
while at the same time protecting the
vulnerable protecting the really elderly
those with serious health conditions
those who have been most vulnerable to
this virus we can protect them and let
everyone else get back to work
while practicing sound social distancing
to slow the spread of the virus so
senator Cruz you know we've been
watching as this has become a seriously
partisan issue a lot of people
suggesting that if people are urging to
go back to work then that is because
they don't care enough about human life
what do you make of those criticisms it
seems like enormous number of bad faith
criticisms happening out there
well unfortunately the media and and and
many partisan Democrats are just
consumed by hatred for Donald Trump so
everything is defined with respect to
Trump and Trump bad is the only thing
they can convey the core in the middle
of a crisis let's let's come together
yacht that there was one media person
Pakistan of Florida sent out a tweet
going yay all these Trump supporters are
going to go get get the virus and died
like hell's wrong with you people let's
not be wishing death on anybody you know
fine you want to disagree on politics
okay but but look America has made it
through massive challenges in the
history of our nation two world wars the
Great Depression 9/11 but we make it
through by coming together and this sort
of deranged Trump hatred it is not
helpful and the idea that if you're
going back to work you want people to
die well that's just
dumb we want to protect lives and we
want to protect lives from the disease
but we also want to protect lives from
poverty and misery and suffering and
unless what anyone trying to solve this
situation would want to do so senator
Cruz there's been a lot of talk about
what China should should have to pay in
order to redress the fact that this
whole thing happened because trying to
decide to lied for weeks about human
human transmission why to the w-h-o
allow millions of citizens to leave the
lu han province and then travel abroad
spreading this thing and seeding it all
over planet Earth what do you think is
the proper measure that should be taken
by the federal government on this
there's been talk by some that we should
somehow cancel China's debt I don't know
that that's possible what do you think
are the options on the table I think
China bears enormous responsibility
enormous culpability for for this
devastation on multiple fronts number
one we know that there were two
laboratories in Wuhan within miles of
where the outbreak began that were
controlled by the Chinese Communist
government and that we're studying back
coronaviruses the Chinese government
refuses to answer the question whether
they were studying this exact virus
whether it was an accidental escape that
triggers this global pandemic number one
number two we know for a fact that the
Chinese government actively suppressed
covered up and hid evidence of this
outbreak when when heroic physician
whistleblowers tried to draw attention
to it the Chinese government came down
on them it punished them it reprimanded
them it silenced them and weeks went by
where any responsible government with an
outbreak like this would have gone in
with public health professionals would a
quarantine those affected and and and
and there is a real possibility we could
have contained this as a regional
outbreak but because China wanted to
save face wanted to hide their
dereliction of duty they allowed this to
become a global pandemic and in a very
real sense the hundred and seventy
thousand plus lives that have been lost
to this pandemic are the direct
responsibility of the Chinese Communist
government the trillions of dollars of
economic devastation I can direct
respond
stability of the Chinese government and
we need number one a thorough accounting
the United States and the entire
community of civilized nations should
not allow China just a stone foot wall
as obvious Kate and refused to answer
questions about whether they mistakenly
released this plague on the world and
number two there need to be real and
serious consequences for their cover up
killing lives and destroying trillions
in economic work so senator Cruz and the
media have spent an inordinate amount of
attention focusing their ire as you
mentioned on President Trump they have
these press conferences every single day
in which they basically just yell at
Trump for you know an hour about how all
of these things he should have done in
February and March weren't done it's
it's weird to me when when they put pull
out this timeline considering that
literally no one was encouraging
shutting down the entire American
economy in February like no one
including the most ardent advocates
nobody was talking about lockdown orders
being put in place in February in fact
mayor Garcetti here in Los Angeles
allowed the LA Marathon to take place on
March 8th obviously you had Mayor Bill
DeBlasio in New York encouraging people
to go to Chinatown for Chinese New Year
he had dancer Pelosi doing the same
thing what do you make of the double
standard that's been applied in terms of
the political measures that were
recommended by various members of the
different parties well it's even worse
than that it's not that no one was
recommending a lockdown that there was
there was leadership which is the
president on January 31st shut down air
travel to and from China and when he did
it on January 31st he was blasted Joe
Biden called in hysterical and
xenophobic Nancy Pelosi introduced
legislation to undo the China travel ban
I talked to the president two days after
he did it he asked me then did I do the
right thing because he was getting a lot
of criticism the New York Times ran
multiple op eds ting him for having shut
down air travel to and from China I told
him on February 2nd mr. president you
didn't exactly the right thing
this is dangerous and you're acting to
protect human lives now the president
was right and Pelosi and Biden and the
New York timing the entire mainstream
media were wrong and they were wrong
over and over
over again when the president halted
travel to and from Europe again the
media got all hysterical say this is
ridiculous who would possibly do that he
was about a week later where all the
European countries halted travel between
each other for the same reason listen
this thing is serious this thing is
deadly and in hindsight everyone can
always second-guess what was done and
say we should have done more that's true
in any crisis but the absolute hypocrisy
of the media that that criticized him
I'll give you an example then the New
York Times wrote a story that said well
you know the China travel ban was not
that severe because 40,000 people
travelled to the US after the travel ban
that's true in the period before 400,000
going back and forth but the period
after 40,000 went back so 90% was
restricted what the President did allow
was US citizens and US permanent
residents to return home and require
that they be quarantine now apparently
the press and the Dems after attacking
the president for opposing the travel
ban they're complaining is you know what
it should have been stricter we called
it xenophobic and hysterical when you
did it but now we wish it have been
stressful listen the political games
need to stop we need to solve this
problem and and defeat this pandemic and
when we're going to do so senator Cruz
final question for you President Trump
getting a lot of flack for the the
announcement that he's going to shut
down immigration what have you seen in
terms of that policy and why exactly are
the same Democrats who have now reversed
on Trump's travel ban from China now
taking the side they took back in
January and saying that an immigration
shutdown for the moment is a good idea
well we'll see the precise details of
the proposal but you're already seeing
some Democrats criticizing and in it
it's the same reason they oppose the
China travel ban it's the same reason
they oppose blocking traffic travel from
countries in Europe where the where the
pandemic was raging you know when it
comes to integration number one in the
midst of a pandemic enforcing borders
and slowing down international travel is
basic common sense it's a way to protect
America and keep us
and you know over a month ago I shared a
hearing in the Senate on the coronavirus
and we heard testimony from the CDC from
the Department of Transportation and
Customs and Border Patrol all three of
the expert witnesses there testified to
the Senate that the travel ban on China
in January 31st that it saved lives and
it reduced the number of cases the
United States I think the president's
announcement when immigrant integration
yesterday did exactly the same thing but
secondly and this is a premise that the
Democrats of the media refused to
acknowledge legal immigration exists for
the benefits of the United States of
America for American workers listen I am
the son of an immigrant came here
legally to this country legal
immigration legal is a great strength of
this country when we got 30 million
Americans out of work we don't have a
need to be bringing in a million plus
people from outside the country for jobs
when the job market is tight when we
need skilled labor legal immigration in
the great strength and and the Democrats
in the media refuse to acknowledge that
that that look we need to put American
workers first that is a concept at
today's Democratic Party that that is
the party of coastal elites and in the
rich rather than working men and women
they don't acknowledge that the
blue-collar workers that are being put
out in the streets that are having
trouble making rent that it makes
perfect sense to say hey let's pause new
workers coming into this economy until
we can get Americans back in the
workplace and senator Cruz really
appreciate your time hang in there sir
Anza and good luck on fighting these
battles appreciate it thank you my
friend god bless
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content